oh good movie girl we're the fat 5 from
Netflix a square eye and these are our
favorite films one of my favorite LGBTQ
movies is Brokeback Mountain because I
actually grew up on a ranch in the
country and I could really relate to two
guys who lived in a country types what
are you laughing at maybe see that I
could come out be gay because there were
Cowboys that were gay I wish I knew how
to quit you moonlight just as an
african-american man who grew up in the
south
seeing that true experience of what it
was like for me and some of my friends
of coming into your own with your
sexuality and finding support and love
just was really amazing and authentic
and inspiring and so I love moon life
you know my rule is our love and our
pride in this house the film that
although I love I have a lot of issues
with it it's Tom Ford's film a single
man there is good but there's a scene in
there where they're sitting on this on
this couch and one of them is playing a
crossword puzzle or something the other
one is reading and I just remember that
moment where their legs were sort of
crossed together and I remember like the
first relationship that I ever had with
a guy the first time that I ever had
like the physical contact of connecting
legs and how scared and excited I was at
the same time and I feel like you really
captured that well we know what listen
that's not the scene you were saying was
problematic no that's even beautiful
scene in the film the second time I saw
the movie I kind of got a little I
really with like the colors changing
yeah it got a little dramatic but then
you know what Julianne Moore just brings
it right back
she's a legend what could be better than
being tucked up here with you my
favorite LGBTQ movie is call me by your
name I know it's very recent but it just
it was beautifully done it was visually
stunning and the story I found really
captivating I remember being young and
wanting to be with a much older guy and
that scene where Timothy Charlemagne's
character is in the car and he's crying
because the guy has left I think we all
connect with that when our first
boyfriend leaves no you don't remember
be a problematic from begin
and for me I'm sorry you don't remember
when you was 1617 ready being into like
a hundred that grown man was backed into
me there was a problem no it was
beautiful it was beautiful it was
beautiful shut up Robert a big one the
HBO made-for-tv film honey classic gia
Annie that movie will make you cry she
was a supermodel in the 70s who
contracted HIV AIDS before anyone knew
what it was it's like a mockup woman
it's not a mockumentary it's like a fake
documentary who are just lesbian scenes
stealing cars walking runways blamming
heroin all over New York City honey that
movie is intense yes it is I cried so
much so Gia
you